[Music]
all right let's go back to man the city
with the best food in America San
Antonio Texas and talk to Stacy what's
up
Stacy hey Dr John how are you what up
I'm doing good how about you oh I've
been better it's been a pretty rough
year if I was doing great I wouldn't be
talking to you that's well played well
played I'm not laughing with you not at
you so what's up what's up if I wasn't
laughing I'd be crying right right I
totally get it what's up okay so I'm I'm
newly divorced and I'm trying to
navigate this and I'm having I'm having
some issues how how long how long were
you married 21 years I'm
45 a long time you're 45 yeah uhhuh yeah
yeah we have two kids 19 and 21 oh gez
okay what
happened
um long and short of things uh he
admitted to me he was cheating with a
20-some year
old oh
um
and
um just say it we're here just say
it uh throughout the divorce I I did
some
digging and I with the help of a friend
found him on
some vicarious
website and he's been going to intimacy
parties sex parties yeah yeah intimacy
parties sounds like people are telling
like secrets and passing
notes uh it's the best way I could
describe it I found out uh he had on
this
website that I found pictures and videos
of him doing things in my home
I found out he has been crossdressing
yeah that he has engaged in the opposite
sex and this was unbeknownst to
me and um during the
divorce I was advised by my lawyer not
to confront him about this why I didn't
why why why why why
why she it was pretty much well I ended
up with darn near everything in the
divorce okay so it was just were going
to win anyway and she want to Cloud it
up yeah okay all right all right yeah so
um before the divorce was Final um I did
start having um little hints here and
there of I know what you've been doing
and and so he he did
eventually confess to me that and he
said he has a sex addiction okay um and
I'm
gonna um there's a lot to this of course
I'm just going to unpack a little bit um
just to give him the benefit of the
doubt um and I don't know why I have to
give that to him but here I am hey can
we can we do something can we do
something are we going to breathe yeah
let's breathe
um okay um yeah let's take a breath I'm
gonna do something I don't normally
do yeah I don't want to give him the
benefit of the doubt
oh okay I don't want to you know why
because he's not on the phone I don't
really care about him right now okay I
care about you and you've been giving
people the the D benefit of the doubt
for your whole
life you've been letting people run all
over you for your whole life
Fair actually that's not true people
have been running all over you when
you're a kid you can't help that I
shouldn't have said it like that I'm
sorry I still let him
well here we
are I don't want to I don't want to hear
his story right now his Saab
story well
um I had cuz you're hold on cuz you're
sitting in the ash of that mess oh it's
so messy I
know he
ruined um I told him he took away my
kids innocence he took away my dreams my
future a bomb was just dropped and we
had no choice in the
matter and I don't know how to parent
right now um I'm an anxious
MTH which shouldn't cause stress or
anxiety causes me to just lash out and
I'm almost into just Frozen mode like
things I just can't make
decisions and
I this man needs help for my kid's sake
he needs therapy he needs to get into
help find help but but I have begged him
and he hasn't and I don't know how to
parent my kids I don't know if I should
say keep keep talking to him keep the
the Line open or if I should just step
back and let them see him for his true
colors because I feel like I'm
constantly catching the bombs he's
throwing because he's still screwing up
in their lives have you sat down with
your kids and talked to them about what
happened happened what you
found uh one not the
other why one not why one not the other
I don't think my son could handle it why
do you think that both of your kids are
adults why do you think that he's uh
he's very very sensitive kid he actually
actually woke me up at 11 o'clock last
night and said Mom I just need a hug and
he was crying that's right and I and I
don't know why I asked him you come on
let's talk he's like no I don't want to
talk I just need a hug that's right
you're home base for him right now but
can I tell you to a sensitive
kid as Dr Becky calls him deeply feeling
children yeah a parent who's not being
fully open especially to an adult child
the kid
knows and what that kid feels is your
rage and your anger and your complete
bewilderment walking around in the woods
like your house is like like walking
around after tornado knocked over
everything just that days you know yeah
yeah and that poor kid thinks it's his
fault because he doesn't know what's
going
on and so he feels crazy and you're
going to watch him revert back to very
childlike behaviors like Mom can I just
cuddle with you because that's his
nervous system trying to be regulated
because he doesn't know what is going on
and I'm not saying badmouth
dad I'm saying look your 19yearold and
your 21y old in the eye and say I'm not
okay yeah I found out that your
father has violated the terms of our
marriage over and over and over
again for our entire
marriage yeah and that's not talk you're
not being egregious you're not like I
got videos none of that stuff right you
can say I've seen evidence of it it's
part of the reason we got
divorced but every and it caught me
completely off
guard yeah your Dad's sick he's not well
he's not
okay I know we love him I still love him
you love
him but he's not
okay very very far distance yeah that is
very different than that man's a piece
of crap and he would that's different
we're not goingon to engage in that
right I I get to do that right I get to
say
but I I don't have the energy for that
that's right that's right you
don't um but hold on hold on before we
go to the next
thing you can't you you acknowledged all
the hurting people on this
thing yeah except for
Stacy
yeah and you've probably heard me if you
listen to the show ever I say this all
the time in these kind of situations but
this one's extra
scary the the person who's most just has
evaporated in front of themselves is
you can you tell me like with all
honesty just like hand on your heart you
had no idea something was going on like
this I had no idea okay that's okay but
here's the deal you have to understand
the trauma that that is because now the
person you don't trust most in the world
is
you and it makes you feel crazy doesn't
it
yeah like how could you not know this
was going on in your house and here's
what I want to tell
you you were married to
somebody who violated you at every step
of the way this is not your fault
okay then what's wrong with me
what
babe what is wrong with me your whole
world just blew
up your sense of self is gone your
marriage is gone the picture you had of
your kids moving off to college and you
and your husband creating this new world
when they were gone is gone it's all
gone of course you're lashing out at
people of course your body's anxious is
all bloody hell of course it
is and you've heard of fight or flight
we don't talk about it but there's fight
flight or freeze there comes a moment
when it's so the trauma is so
overwhelming your body just shuts the
system off because it can't it can't
compute at all it can't
respond what do I
do first thing is I want you to take as
deep breath as possible right now and
hold it
okay hold it for a count of four one two
three till almost Burns four
exhale did you let it
out yeah okay now I want you to take
your shoulders and I want you to burrow
them up under your ears as tight as you
possibly can for a count of three squish
them up there one two three and then
drop them all the way down
okay
yeah what room are you in right
now my car in your car all right I want
my son to hear y
okay I want you to count the
buttons on your dashboard right right
now on your uh radio your car radio does
it have buttons on it or was one of
those new fangled computery buttony
things it's got buttons count them for
me count them out loud one two three
four five six seven oh there's a lot
eight okay that's good you get hey you
get the point here's what we're
doing often when people's entire world
had blown up their marriage was over
someone had a loved one had walked had
passed away
I would hold their hand and we would
walk down the street and we' count
cracks in the sidewalk okay here's what
we're doing we're bringing our body to
right
now
okay we're still breathing right now the
sun is out right
now okay y I'm going to give you a
couple ideas on what to do next is your
divorce final final okay I I actually
just got my name back today okay okay
and that's both freeing and devastating
isn't
it it's scary
yeah and when you said you got almost
everything in the divorce do you are you
have economic stability or you got to go
to work on Monday oh no I'm fine
okay couple of things I want you to do
ASAP number one do you have a a
girlfriend or two or three that you can
call and tell everything
to
um I made a
deal with him that I would not yeah that
deal is out the window ba ficia
gone okay that deal will kill you
Stacy yeah because what that deal is is
him destroying your life and you laying
on top of the burning shrapnel of the
bomb he
threw I'm not saying go run him in the
dirt publicly or make f Facebook forums
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about you need some people in
your life that you can say everything's
over and I got to build from
scratch
uhhuh okay do you have two or three
women you trust that you can sit down
with yeah is this quote unquote deal you
made is it legally binding is that a
part of your decree no
good it's not your job to carry him
anymore okay
that's what I feel like I'm carrying his
burden that's not your
job the second thing I want you to do
after you get a group of women here's
the deal I want you to text them and I
want you to meet them for coffee when
you say I want to meet y'all for coffee
and I want you to tell them out loud
I've selected you two or three women to
walk with me through hell are y'all
in okay I'm coming out a divorce nobody
knows the truth of what I just found
what I just went through what my kids
are going through through and I need a
group of women that I can text at 2:
a.m. I need a group of women I can text
at noon and you'll text me back when you
can and just say I love you or just say
I'll be up I'll be over with burritos
later yeah okay when you do that your
body will exhale a little bit because it
knows it's not carrying this whole thing
by
itself okay I love you enough to tell
you you cannot carry all this by
yourself it's too big yeah okay it's
yeah
second thing I want you to do is I want
you to get a journal of some
sort okay you can go to Walmart for nine
bucks if you've got the money get a nice
one for 50 bucks with a leather bounding
on it and I want you to write in it
because your kids are going to read this
after you pass away I want you to ride
in
it when you feel like I quote unquote
should do
something I shouldn't say this I should
go do this I need to do this I have to
do this I want you to write those things
down
and I want you to draw an arrow across
that page and say his burden or my
burden okay yeah I need to make sure
that they nope that's his
job his job is to explain to your kids
why he chose to cheat on his mom on
their mom not his mom on their mom for
years why he chose to have sex parties
in y'all's family home while they were
gone while y'all were gone that's his
job that is not your job
okay when he says I don't have any money
your mom took everything it is his job
to tell your kids the
truth it's his job to go get a job to
rebuild a career at 45 years old or
whatever he's got to do that's his job
not yours it's his job to go get
psychological care or medical care or
whatever he
needs your job is to make sure you're
financially and phisically safe and
sound and to make sure your kids know
they are loved and they can always come
home it might mean you sell the house
cuz I don't want to be in that house
anymore I sold it good for you but I I
moved to our vacation home so yeah
that's probably dumb how far away is
that I it's 16 hours south of where I
live I've got friends here too okay all
right all right as long as you got a
community uh I was going to tell you
don't make any decisions for the next
six months or a year but that's cool um
I had to get out of that house no that's
I know that I know that I know that but
I'm glad you sold it I'm glad it's gone
um here is a thing you probably don't
want to hear but hopefully you've
already done it but maybe you haven't
you need to go get a full battery of
blood test including all the STI tests
don't avoid that any longer okay have
you already done that I've done that I'm
clear you're clear you're good yeah ah
fantastic that was that was scary yeah
yeah I know I know waiting for that test
could
be
okay and sometime soon you're going to
need somebody to talk to to process this
and what you're going to be processing
is yes the trauma and yes the questions
about how to answer your kids all the
mechanical stuff is fine but the big
thing you're going to be processing is
how do I trust me again because I missed
something that big for 21 years what you
feel like you actually had the wool
pulled over your eyes for 21 years you
were married to somebody with a deep and
profound pathology that hid from you and
hid from you and destroyed your life yes
it's not yours to carry but you do have
to pick up the ashes now because he's
gone
yeah when you ask me where do I start
I'm going to tell you the starting line
is
reality that's the next chapter of my
[Laughter]
book are you reading my book yeah I just
hit the
uh the bridge I just finished the bridge
about to get reality well you're in it
now here we go and what what I'm GNA
tell you in that chapter is this take
out a piece of paper and say what is the
actual state of my
life what's my financial State who are
three or four people write their names
down and their phone numbers down in a
piece of paper that I can call if I need
to what is my you can't just not have a
job you have to have a purpose you got
to get up and go do something on a
regular basis
what is that thing going to
be and uh I'm
disabled of course right and I don't say
of course I'm just saying why not add
another complex variable to the
situation right right so um but maybe
your purpose maybe your purpose
is moderating an online forum for women
who find out that their whole world has
been a sham yeah maybe it is working in
a disability rights office maybe it's
working at a Lo local University to help
students navigate naate the 504 ad8
process right it can be any number of
things right it may be working for an
online University from home on how to
help students who need some
accommodations in navigating their their
professors all that kind of there's work
to do there's purpose in where you find
yourself
okay and what I want to encourage you is
Do not sit at home with the shades
drawn that pours gasoline on the on the
freeze part of your life
okay that pours gas on
it when somebody takes off to run a
marathon nobody says all right see you
in a few minutes they say I'll see you
in a few
hours it's easy when you're in this
process that you're in now of no fault
of your
own to get frustrated by how slow the
progress is you are running three
back-to-back marathons it's going to be
a while before you
have
peace that's why doing the next right
thing is so
important the next right thing is
calling a friend the next right thing is
seeing a counselor the next right thing
is making sure you have a journal where
you're getting all these thoughts and
these spinning things out of your body
and onto the
paper it's any kind of movement you can
do in line in alignment with your
disability whatever you got to do to do
the next right thing and the next right
thing and I don't care if you feel like
it I don't care if you feel like it just
keep doing the next right thing because
you're going to open your eyes in 18
months you're going to open your eyes in
two years you're going to open your eyes
in a
year and you're going to realize you're
breathing again and the sun came
out and it's called
hope it's called hope Stacy you call me
anytime and I'll walk with you in any
situation you find yourself in never
think you don't have somebody in your
corner cuz I'm here call those friends
in your local community call them
today thank you so much for your
bravery